From a messy behind-the-scenes romance to
a Twitter tirade that sank the entire show,
the making of Roseanne was just as chaotic
as the lives of its on-screen characters.
Getting Roseanne to the small screen wasn't
easy.
In the 1980s, television producers Marcy Carsey
and Tom Werner wanted to make a series about
a working mother.
They commissioned a script from writer Matt
Williams, and thought that Roseanne Barr's
"domestic goddess" persona would be a perfect
fit.
But Barr and Williams were combative from
the start.
Vanity Fair reported that Williams wanted
to call it Life and Stuff to keep Barr from
having too much control, but Barr wanted to
simply call it Roseanne.
Barr got her title, but it was just the first
in a series of battles between the star and
the writer.
"You know what would be really good for breakfast?"
"What?"
"Pie."
"Tell him no."
"No."
While Williams is credited as the sole creator
of Roseanne, Barr reportedly wanted credit
since she felt the show was based on her life.
Williams, Carsey, and Werner claimed it was
actually a matter with the Writers Guild of America.
Mere weeks into production, Barr wanted Williams
fired and threatened to leave the show.
Williams did bow out, but not before taking
a large financial settlement for his efforts.
There was never any doubt that John Goodman
would play Dan Conner on Roseanne.
Before being cast, Goodman had a series of
small roles in classic '80s films like Revenge
of the Nerds and Raising Arizona, but he was
hardly a star.
Werner claimed that they were looking for
an actor who could match Barr's charisma,
and Goodman nailed his screen test.
However, while ABC wanted Roseanne to move
quickly into production, Goodman had a scheduling conflict.
But Werner and Casey were so confident of
his talents that they forfeited a coveted
time slot in order to keep Goodman in the
role.
"One kid down, two to go, Darlene."
In a career retrospective for Vanity Fair,
Goodman recalled how he liked the script and
immediately hit it off with Barr.
Goodman left his audition knowing he had the
job, something that rarely happened to him.
He found job security in the role of Dan Conner,
playing the character for years — not only
in Roseanne, but also its popular spin-off
series, The Conners.
Barr and Tom Arnold were longtime friends
on the stand-up comedy circuit before they
fell in love while taping Roseanne's 1987
HBO comedy special, The Roseanne Barr Show.
While Barr was married and Arnold was in a
relationship, they soon were inseparable.
Arnold became, and was subsequently fired,
from his gig as Roseanne's warm-up comedian,
but he was eventually hired on the show's
writing staff after Barr's insistence.
The pair married in 1990.
In addition to playing the character Arnie
Thomas, Arnold ascended to executive producer
on Roseanne, and essentially took control
of Barr's career, leading Barr to fire most
of her team.
At the time of their marriage, a source told
Vanity Fair,
"Roseanne is oblivious to everything but Tom
Arnold."
The couple brought their outlandish behavior
to the set of Roseanne, even igniting rumors
that they were engaged in a three-way relationship
with their assistant-turned-executive Kim Silva.
Soon after — in 1994 — Barr and Arnold's
marriage ended, and so did Arnold's time on Roseanne.
Barr fired Arnold and Silva, and reportedly
changed the locks on their production office.
Roseanne wasn't the only TV collaboration
between Barr and Arnold.
The pair produced multiple short-lived sitcoms,
including The Jackie Thomas Show and Tom.
In 1992, while Roseanne was the number one
show on television, The Jackie Thomas Show
was designed to be a vehicle for Arnold, making
its debut that December.
According to The New York Times, ABC was concerned
about putting the poorly tested show in the
coveted and highly lucrative time slot directly
after Roseanne.
The show had promising debut ratings, but
its decline in viewership left ABC hesitant
to renew it for another season.
That's when things got ugly.
"What happened?
Well, I'll tell you what happened, the big
monkey ate the little monkey."
In 1993, Barr reportedly threatened to take
Roseanne to another network in retaliation
for what she perceived to be disrespect over
The Jackie Thomas Show, all the while sending
scathing faxes to negative critics.
While Arnold told the press that Jackie Thomas
was picked up for a second season, it was
only a tactic to bully ABC into renewing the
show.
Ultimately, Arnold left Jackie Thomas to develop
the sitcom Tom for CBS.
But this new sitcom only had a short run in
1994 before being canceled.
The Roseanne chicken shirt has become one
of television's most recognized pieces of
anti-fashion.
Barr wrote for Vulture that she clashed with
the wardrobe department early in the show's
production, so she ended up wearing her own
clothes on the set.
After this dispute, Roseanne's wardrobe department
apparently developed a sense of humor.
They introduced the chicken shirt — first
worn by Lecy Goranson's Becky — as a joke
in Season 2.
But once Barr saw the design, its ugliness
became something of an artistic statement.
The shirt went on to play heavily in Season
5's finale episode "Daughters and Other Strangers."
It rotated among cast members, with numerous
actors sporting the garment during the episode.
The chicken shirt would live on as Roseanne's
apron design at her restaurant, the Lanford
Lunch Box.
It also appears during Season 10's opening
credits.
Called "incalculably ill-judged" by the Rotten
Tomatoes Critics Consensus, "strange, scattered,
and self-conscious" by Vulture, and one of
the worst series finales of all-time by Variety,
Season 9 of Roseanne left longtime fans confused
and even alienated.
When Season 9 was announced, The New York
Times reported that both Barr and ABC decided
it would be the show's last.
Breaking from the show's working-class family
strife, the final season saw the Conners win
$108 million in the lottery.
The season bounced between wish-fulfillment
stories and self-referential television parodies,
with John Goodman's Dan Conner notably absent
from most of the season's episodes.
This was due to Goodman walking away from
Roseanne because he was reportedly fed up
with the on-set drama.
The Roseanne finale, when the entire lottery
premise is revealed to be Roseanne's fantasy
after Dan had passed away, remains controversial
to this day.
"Yeah and I got you some notepads.
"And I got you a dictionary and a thesaurus."
"You know, Stephen King started this way."
Even though Season 9 was billed as the show's
swan song, there were talks of a Roseanne
spin-off series.
The Los Angeles Times claimed the show would
have seen Roseanne and Michael Fishman's D.J.
moving to Las Vegas.
With ABC balking at the show's high price,
the idea didn't stick.
An unlikely meeting of comedy divas happened
during Season 9's Halloween episode "Satan,
Darling," when Roseanne crossed over with
the UK comedy sensation Absolutely Fabulous.
In the episode, newly minted millionaire Roseanne
and her sister Jackie attended a party in
New York City, where she meets London fashion
mavens Patsy and Edina — played by Joanna
Lumley and Jennifer Saunders, respectively.
The foursome drink excessively and the episode
transitions into a parody of the 1968 horror
film Rosemary's Baby.
Roseanne's connection to Absolutely Fabulous
is not entirely inorganic.
In 1995, The New York Times reported that
Barr purchased the rights to produce an American
version of the BBC series.
The project was a hot commodity in Hollywood,
but AbFab never got off the ground.
Instead, Barr and Saunders collaborated on
"Satan, Darling," with Saunders later recounting,
"It was very bizarre.
We were quite confused.
But it was fun."
While Barr is revered as a trailblazing female
talent bucking the system of Hollywood, she's
also known for being a difficult boss.
Barr admitted to ABC News that she made a
list of people whom she'd fire when the show
reached number one in the ratings, and she
eventually followed through.
Roseanne writer and executive producer Bruce
Helford was warned by his agent and lawyer
that Barr fires everyone after one year.
Sure enough, he was eventually canned.
Even future television powerhouse Chuck Lorre
was the focus of Barr's ire.
He told the Television Academy that he was
almost fired because she hated his first script.
Writers on Roseanne recalled to EW how Barr
dehumanized them by referring to them by numbers
instead of names.
Barr, on the other hand, claimed that the
practice stripped the writers of their self-entitlement
and that they learned something from the practice.
While some writers clashed with her abrasive
management, Barr credits herself for championing
female writers and giving then-unknown talents
like Joss Whedon and Judd Apatow their first
writing gigs.
Lecy Goranson and Sarah Chalke both played
the Conners' eldest daughter, Becky.
Goranson originated the character, playing
her for the show's first five seasons.
However, the role was recast when Goranson
decided to attend college.
According to EW, after testing hundreds of
actors for the role, Chalke was cast.
While Chalke was around for part of Season
6 and all of Season 7, Goranson was able to
mix her higher education pursuits with her
sitcom stardom.
She returned to Roseanne for parts of Season
8, sharing the role with Chalke.
Though Chalke was the show's sole Becky for
Season 9.
The humor of having two actors play the same
character — sometimes in the same season
— was not lost on Roseanne.
The show included self-aware jokes about Goranson
and Chalke playing the same role, including
a parody of The Patty Duke Show theme song
in Season 8.
When Roseanne returned for Season 10 in 2018,
both Goranson and Chalke came back to the show.
A new role was created for Chalke and, for
the first time, both actors shared the screen.
Before Roseanne, Halloween-themed network
television episodes were few and far between.
The show arguably contributed to the invention
of dedicated spooky season episodes.
Roseanne Barr told Yahoo! Entertainment that
ABC initially resisted making Roseanne Halloween
episodes — fearing it would alienate part
of their audience.
However, Barr argued that Halloween was popular,
and after she won the debate, she called the
victory, quote, "the first dragon we slayed
on the Roseanne show."
With the network greenlighting the concept,
the beloved tradition was born in Season 2's
episode "BOO!," where the Conners stage a
haunted house for trick-or-treaters.
"This is the only way out.
Follow me into the enchanted garage."
In every subsequent season, the show pulled
out all the stops to celebrate Halloween.
Elaborate costumes, hilarious pranks, and
frightful antics had viewers tuning in to
see who could out-scare whom.
Goodman reportedly joked that the Conners
were poor because they spent all their money
on Halloween.
Even if the Conners went broke celebrating
the season, the amount of fun they had was priceless.
Roseanne Barr wrote for Vulture that, when
developing the show, she needed Roseanne to
not just be funny, but also about the struggle
to survive, and breaking taboos.
The show aired episodes on domestic violence,
racism, teen sex, and drugs; but not without resistance.
Barr fought with network censors over several
issues, including episodes about menstruation
and same-sex kissing.
The Season 1 episode "Nightmare on Oak Street"
made headlines for its groundbreaking depiction
of Sara Gilbert's Darlene experiencing her
first period.
Barr later told Oprah that the episode met
with resistance from ABC, saying,
"It was hard because that had never been on
television."
Later in the show's run, ABC alleged that
the Season 6 episode "Don't Ask, Don't Tell"
— which featured a kiss between Roseanne
and Mariel Hemingway's Sharon at a gay bar
— violated network standards and refused
to air the episode.
After Barr's demand that the episode be shown,
it was eventually released, reportedly garnering
nearly 20 million viewers.
During its heyday, Roseanne was one of the
most popular television shows in America,
so it might come as a surprise that it was
virtually snubbed by TV's most prestigious award.
The show was a consistent hit for ABC and
was recognized by The New York Times in 1994
as "the most watched entertainment show in
television over the past five years."
Despite its popularity, Roseanne wasn't nominated
for a single Emmy Award for Outstanding Comedy
Series during its 10-season run.
"Mom used to yell at us in the shower.
It was like that scene in Psycho.
Take out the trash!"
Roseanne Barr lamented her initial lack of
Emmy recognition to the Los Angeles Times
and claimed it was likely retribution for
on-set controversies.
Barr eventually won an Emmy for Outstanding
Lead Actress in a Comedy Series in 1993, with
Goodman and Laurie Metcalf receiving multiple
Emmys for their work on the series.
While Roseanne certainly earned its acting
accolades, it can be baffling that the show
itself was never recognized in its totality.
In 2017, the news broke that most of Roseanne's
original cast would reprise their roles for
a limited series revival on ABC.
Even as the excitement mounted, there was
the problem of how to address the continuation
of the series after its Season 9 finale.
Well, it's television after all, and Roseanne
chose to simply ignore most of Season 9's finale.
In Season 10's opener, Dan is still alive
and other questions — like who exactly Darlene
and Becky married — were left unanswered.
The first episode of the Roseanne revival
pulled in over 18 million viewers, the highest
network comedy ratings in years.
In fact, Roseanne was 2018's most-watched
series in total viewers.
Despite its popularity, the celebration was
short-lived when ABC canceled the series after
Barr posted racist comments on Twitter.
ABC Entertainment president Channing Dungey
stated,
"Roseanne's Twitter statement is abhorrent,
repugnant and inconsistent with our values,
and we have decided to cancel her show."
Roseanne was a serious incubator for up-and-coming
Hollywood talent, with many members of the
show becoming some of entertainment's most
powerful players.
Amy Sherman-Palladino — creator of Gilmore
Girls and The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel — super
producer Chuck Lorre, and Buffy the Vampire
Slayer mastermind Joss Whedon were all in
the writer's room.
Judd Apatow shared on Tell Me More with Kelly
Corrigan that supporting Barr with her joke
writing was his first big job, and even Norm
Macdonald penned several Roseanne episodes
before his achieving stardom on Saturday Night
Live.
"You know, the old man was almost a state
champ back in high school."
"Were you ever in a cage match?"
"Only with your mom."
Although some might have forgotten George
Clooney on Roseanne, he played Jackie's love
interest Booker Brooks in the show's first
season.
Before Clooney became an Oscar-winning movie
star and filmmaker, he was just a working
guy sporting a pencil behind his ear.
While audiences became acquainted with Johnny
Galecki as David on Roseanne, he eventually
catapulted into global fame on The Big Bang
Theory.
Sara Gilbert parlayed her role as Darlene
into a successful producing career, co-creating
the CBS chat show The Talk.
She also initiated and executive produced
the Roseanne revival.